[JINGLE PLAYS]
There is a
bs_theme_preview function
that, given that
you don't already
have a Shiny
application that you
want to preview a theme for, you
can give me bs_theme_preview--
like, if I already had
in mind like a theme
that I wanted to use and didn't
want to do the work of actually
programming a Shiny app example,
I can just save this theme here
and use this bs_theme_preview,
give it a theme,
and it will apply that
theme to this Shiny demo
app that kind of tries its best
to stuff all of the core Shiny
UI stuff that we support
into this example app.
So you can see how
those styles would
end up affecting slider input,
and selectize input, and date
input, as well as things
like verbatim text output
and all of the sort
of Shiny widgets
that you may or may
not be already used to.
And then it also,
at the same time,
overlays this interactive
widget that I can drag around
and use to make tweaks to
the actual theme settings.
So I can change from
something closer
to a black to something closer
to like an ice blue theme.
So it's got the two main
background and foreground
colors.
It's also got the ability
to use a Bootswatch
theme if you want to.
Just be aware, if you
use a Bootswatch theme,
don't expect the custom
theming options to always
work super great with it.
So just want to set
expectations there,
that just because of the way
that Bootswatch is currently
set up, they haven't implemented
those things well enough
in mine to allow you to
tweak them in ways that work
as well as just using the
default bootstrap theme.
So just be aware of that.
So you can change the main
background-foreground, as well
as I could have a different
primary color here.
That will change
tabsetPanel, things
like check boxes and radio
buttons, slider inputs also.
We try our best to use
those like main semantics
of bootstrap and propagate them
throughout all of the widgets
that we provide in Shiny.
So the main like color and
Bootswatch settings, as well as
fonts.
And again, this has
integration with Google Fonts,
where I could choose any sans
serif font that I wanted.
Let's choose something like--
I'm not sure how to pronounce
this one, but I do like it--
Monserrat.
So I could change from
prompt to Montserrat.
Oh, and actually,
that might be a bug,
that it seems to have gone back
to my original theme settings.
But now you can
see, at the top here
and on the tabsetPanel, that's
got a slightly different
looking for here.
It also has Thematic
enabled, so that we
can look at how the
theme would actually
be propagated to rplots
defaults settings as well.
So I could, again, change
to a blue color here,
and that will just automatically
kind of propagate to drplot.
Same thing with DT tables.
DT also has some
nice integration
with bslib, where it
derives its sort of accent
colors, and main colors,
and fonts as well--
all those styles--
from the bsloop theme.
And then these are
just some other things
that we provide in Shiny
UI, like modals and progress
bars, notifications.
And then the difference between
how the heading fonts would
look versus code and
base font, and then
some other kind of more
low-level options for more
advanced themeing.
So you can see in my R console
here various output that
has been essentially
echoed as I've made changes
to the theming application.
And it should do a
good job of keeping
track of just the changes that
you've made interactively.
So this captures
the fact that I've
changed to more of a blue
background and foreground
color, as well as the
Monserrat font setting,
and it's not quite smart enough
to know that it should actually
integrate this stuff
with the input theme
that you've given it.
So you will have to essentially
copy this code here.
And it does make the assumption
that your theme is named theme.
But thankfully I've actually
used the name theme.
So I can just say
bs_theme_update this theme
with these new settings.
And now, if I feed this into
input again on the BSD preview,
it'll use the
Montserrat settings.
The bs_theme_preview
is really nice
if, again, you don't
already have a Shiny
app that you're
using, and you want
to get a feel for
what colors and fonts
you might want to use in
your future Shiny app.
But if you already have
an existing Shiny app,
you can leverage that same
interactive theming widget.
So if I already have this
navbar page here, I can--
first, let me actually do more
of a traditional looking set
up.
Here's the server function.
It has the input and output
arguments, as well as session.
And then, bslib has a
function called bs_themer.
Diemer that you can call
inside of your server function,
and then it will overlay
that same interactive themer
on this particular Shiny app.
So now I could go in and do the
same thing to my basic navbnar
page and still get the same
experience of the code being
put to replicate the changes.
And you don't necessarily--
you just need to call this once.
You don't need to
worry about calling
this in a Reactive context
or anything like that.
If you want to do this, just
go to the top of your server
function, and call
this function once,
and then they will
just overlay that.
And you can also collapse it if
you don't actually really want
to use it and you want
to do some other stuff
with your Shiny app.
You can collapse it and kind
of get it out of your way
If you don't want it anymore.
And yeah, not only can
you do this with Shiny,
but you can also do this with
your R Markdown documents.
But there is-- it's a little
bit more tricky to figure out
how to do that, in
the sense that it
requires two different things.
It requires you to add a
runtime Shiny to your R Markdown
document, because
really we can't
get the full features of
this interactive theming
widget working without
a Shiny runtime.
And then, as well,
in your setup chunk,
you want to call this bs_themer.
Sort of like how you called
the bs_themer in the server
function, you want to do the
same thing in code that's going
to run in a server context,
which I can't remember
if that's--
well, actually, looks
like that worked.
So we got this original example
that we're working from,
and now this interactive themer.
So if I wanted to
have a look at one
of these prepackaged
themes, say Minty,
I can see how that will look
on my R Markdown document.
Unfortunately, Thematic won't
work if you're statically
rendering these plots.
So it doesn't know that--
by default, it won't
know to re-render itself
when your theme has changed.
But you can make
that work as well,
if you instead
dynamically render this
through a renderPlot.
Which now we can do.
Because we have
the runtime Shiny,
we can have the ability to
render R plots dynamically.
So let's just make
sure this works
by stopping and running again.
All right.
So it's recognized
the default theme.
But now, if I
change to Minty, it
will know to re-render itself
with those new CSS settings
essentially.